Traductor: Emma Gon
Revisor: Sebastian Betti
Juana Ramírez de Asbaje se sentó
ante un panel de prestigiosos teólogos,
juristas y matemáticos.
El virrey de la Nueva España los había
invitado para examinar su conocimiento
planteándole las preguntas
más difícles que pudieron juntar.
Y Juana respondió
a cada reto con acierto,
desde ecuaciones complicadas
a cuestiones filosóficas.
Los observadores cuentan
que la escena parecía
"un galeón real abriéndose paso
ente unas pocas canoas".
La mujer que enfrentó esta interrogación
nació a mediados del siglo XVII.
En ese entonces, México había sido
una colonia española por más de un siglo,
que se manejaba en un sistema
de clases estratificado y complicado.
Los abuelos maternos de Juana
nacieron en España,
por lo cual fueron miembros de
la clase más estimada de México.
Pero al nacer fuera de matrimonio,
de padre español capitán militar,
que abandonó a su madre, Doña Isabel
crió sola a Juana y sus hermanas.
Por fortuna, los recursos
moderados de su abuelo
aseguraron que la familia
tuviera una vida cómoda.
Y Doña Isabel puso
un sólido ejemplo a sus hijas,
al administrar con éxito una
de las dos fincas de su padre,
a pesar de ser analfabeta
y la misoginia de la era.
Quizá fue este precedente que inspiró
la firme confianza de Juana.
A los tres años, siguió en secreto
a su hermana mayor a la escuela.
Cuando supo después que la educación
superior solo era para hombres,
le rogó a su madre que
la dejara asistir disfrazada.
Con su petición denegada,
Juana se consoló
en la biblioteca privada de su abuelo.
Al inicio de su adolescencia,
dominó el debate filosófico, latín
y el náhuatl de los aztecas.
El intelecto precoz de Juana
llamó la atención
de la corte real
en la Ciudad de México
y a sus 16 años,
el virrey y su esposa la tomaron
como su dama de honor.
Allí, sus obras y poemas deslumbraron
e indignaron por igual a la corte.
Su poema provocativo
Hombres necios que acusáis
repudia los dobles estándares sexistas,
y denuncia cómo los hombres
corrompen a las mujeres
y a la vez las acusan de inmorales.
A pesar de la controversia,
su obra seguía inspirando adoración
y numerosas propuestas.
Pero Juana tenía más interés en
el conocimiento que en el matrimonio.
Y en la sociedad patriarcal de ese tiempo
solo había un lugar para ella:
la iglesia, aunque bajo la celosa
influencia de la Inquisición española
le permitiría conservar
su independencia y respetabilidad,
sin tener que casarse.
A los 20 años, ingresó al
Convento Jerónimo de Santa Paula
y tomó su nuevo nombre:
Sor Juana Inés de la Cruz.
Durante años, Sor Juana fue considerada
un tesoro preciado de la iglesia.
Escribió dramas, comedias y tratados
en filosofía y matemáticas,
además de música religiosa y poesía.
Recopiló una gran biblioteca
y la visitaron muchos
intelectuales prominentes.
Fungió como tesorera
y archivista del convento,
además de proteger el sustento
de sus hermanas y sobrinas
de hombres que intentaron explotarlas.
Pero su franqueza al final la puso
en conflicto con sus benefactores.
En 1690, un obispo publicó una crítica
privada de un sermón respetado.
En esa publicación,
exhortó a Sor Juana a dedicarse
a la oración antes que al debate.
Ella respondió que Dios no le habría
dado inteligencia a las mujeres
si no hubiera querido que lo usaran.
El intercambio capta la atención
del arzobispo conservador de México.
Poco a poco, privan a Sor Juana
de su prestigio,
la obligan a vender sus libros
y a que deje de escribir.
Furiosa de la censura,
pero renuente a dejar la iglesia,
amargamente renueva sus votos.
En su último acto de rebeldía, firma,
"Yo, la peor de todas",
con su propia sangre.
Privada de estudios, Sor Juana
se dedica a obras de beneficencia,
y el 1695, muere de una enfermedad
contraída al cuidar de sus hermanas.
Hoy, Sor Juana es reconocida como
la primer feminista de América.
Es tema de incontables
documentales, novelas y óperas
y aparece en el billete
de 200 pesos en México.
En palabras del Nobel Octavio Paz:
"No basta decir que la obra de
Sor Juana es un producto de la historia:
debemos agregar que la historia
es también un producto de su obra".